Okay, Trey says, are you worried about over saturation of a certain niche, especially concrete.
So here's my thoughts is the same thing with tree service at some point, like if we looked at concrete today. Right. And we said is concrete more saturated with lead generators today than it was a year ago.
Yes or no. Yeah, obviously right it's the same thing with tree service couple years tree service was like this thing that was ready to go and take, take by the throat and whatever right.
In 2020, I made a money, a bunch of money on tree service. I haven't built a tree service site in 18 months. So, do I think there's going to be certain niches that we're going to want to say okay this niche is getting hit pretty hard.
Sure. Yes, 100%. And I have a YouTube video if I can if you can message me I can share it with you, where I talk about this with tree service as an example.
But here's something we're not considering.
Just because you guys got to hear this, just because you see another lead generator in your city does not rule it out.
I thought for the longest time, I will do my research I'm like oh, okay, let's look at this city, and I was like, I would type it in I'm like concrete St. George.
And I'm like, I'm blinking I'm like please tell me there's not only generated I'm scrolling up I'm scrolling up like, oh, gosh, dang it. And I would go and look at when it was index and I was like, dang it I missed it.
I should have done it last year I know I should have done it last year.
And I every time I would see a lead generator I would just run.
And then one day, this is in my own backyard, I started looking at tree service in St. George, Utah.
And then I saw there was a site and I thought, dang it and then you know what I did is like, I'm like, you know what, I'm going to call this site, and I called the website did not call the ads they weren't running ads and guys if you start calling
people's ads I'm going to freaking knock you out do not call someone's ads, especially if they're running ads, and you know they're in this group because they probably are. Don't click on someone's ads that's messed up.
Okay.
I clicked on their organic listing, and I call them. And no one answered I was like dude these guys are on a client, I could tell no one answered I was texting whatever.
And then I found out who it was I think they left their name at the bottom I looked them up on Facebook we had some mutual friends because they were in one of my other groups and I said hey, I saw that you own this site.
Would you be willing to sell it because it looks like you don't have a client. And I don't know if that pissed them off but basically it was like, Nope, Nope, Nope. And I said, Okay, cool.
And then I thought, Dude, even with that website in the top five or three whatever it was.
It's still low hanging fruit. There's still not that much competition.
I'm just going to build it anyway. And my thinking was honest this is when I started to get like the abundance mentality Brian, as I started thinking, dude, there's more than one trade company in this area that's willing to pay for leads there has to be.
And those guys don't even have a client, but even if they did, there has to be more than one company that's willing to pay for advertising.
And so I freaking, I just went for it. And guess what, that site to date, I have made over $25,000. They have not paused the contract once whether it's winter whether it's spring whether it's pandemic whether it's recession, I don't get calls from them.
They've been paying me over $1,000 per month, since March of 2020. So, dude, we're coming up on three years so we're actually we're probably closer to 30 grand if not more I don't even know I'll look at it in my stripe account.
And imagine if I had run away. So, long way of answering your question do I think there's going to be some niches course, there's going to be some, but you also have to remember just because you see a lead generator doesn't mean that it rules it out.
Okay, that's number one.
Number two.
We're always going to be discovering new niches so just so everybody knows, I am currently testing out four to five new niches, and I will probably have kind of my, my breadwinner niche for 2023, that I will be able to say hey this is what I'm focusing on this year in
In 2021, it was artificial grass, and then this year it's been concrete. Okay.
2023 is probably going to be something else but guess what you guys know about me. I will share that niche with you but I don't want to open my mouth until I can confidently say, yes, this is a good niche and I would recommend doing it again and again and again
So, there's that. Good question though.